عبر البناء على ما حققناه سويا في تحالفنا
ضد داعش
ومواصله جهودنا المتضافره والمتكامله
والمنسقه في قادم الايام
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن دوما ان
السبيل الامن ان السبيل الى الامن
والاستقرار والتنميه والازدهار يتطلب
استمرار جهودنا الجماعيه في محاربه
الارهاب وجماعاته المجرمه ومواجهه الفكر
المتطرف الذي يتناقض مع كل القيم الدينيه
والانسانيه والاخلاقيه وستستمر بالعديد في
بدل كل جهد ممكن بالتعاون معكم جميعا في
سبيل دعم جهود التحالف الدولي ضد تنظيم
داعش والقضاء على جميع انشطته وامتداداته
الاجراميه اينما كانت ومواجهه محاولاتها
الشيطانيه في استغلال وتجنيد الاطفال
والشباب وتجفيف في مصادر التمويله ودعمه
كما تحرص المملكه كل الحرص على استقرار
الدول التي استغل هذا التنظيم اراضيها من
اجل تنفيذ مخططاته
التدميريه ومنها سوريا والعراق ونشيد بما
بذله العراق من جهود حاسمه وتنسيق المستمر
مع التحالف الدولي للقضاء على التنظيم
وتقديرا لجهود اخوتنا في العراق فقد ساهمت
المملكه بتمويل مشاريع اعاده الاعمار في
العراق كما تقدم للشكر والتقدير الى
مجموعات العمل التابعه للتحالف الدولي ضد
تنظيم داعش الارهابي على جهودهم في مكافحه
التنظيم ومنع التشابه
ويسعدني ان اعلن عن انضمام المملكه لرئاسه
مجموعه التركيز المعنيه بالشان الافريقي
لمواجهه مخاطر التنظيم الى جانب كل من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومملكه المغرب
وجمهوريه ايطاليا وجمهوريه النيجر كما
ارحب بالتوجه الى انشاء مجموعه التركيز
المعنيه بمكافحه تنظيم داعش ولايه خرسان
في افغانستان حيث ستشكل هذه المجموعه
محورا اساسيا للحد من تواجد وانتشار
التنظيم الارهابي في تلك المناطق اصحاب
السمو والمعالي والسعاده ايمانا من
المملكه بمحاربه الفكر بالفكر واقتلاع افه
الارهاب من جذوره ونبذ الكراهيه والتطرف
لابت المملكه على انشاء عدد من المراكز
لمكافحه الارهاب والافكار المتطرفه ومن
اهمها المركز العالمي لمكافحه الفكر
المتطرف اعتداء والذي يرمي الى مكافحه
الفكر المتطرف ورسائله ونشري مبادئ
التسامح وتعزيز ثقافه الاعتداء ومحاربه
انشطته والحد من الاثار وتقدي العملات
الاعلاميه لتخفيف التاثير الاعلامي لداعش
وذلك بالتعاون مع شركائنا على مستوى
الاقليمي والدولي الحضور الكرام يجب علينا
جميعا العمل على قطع الطريق امام اي فرصه
يمكن لهذا التنظيم استغلالها لاستعماله
وتجنيد اتباع جدد لذلك الغيب بمجموعه عمل
مكافحه داعيه دعايه داعش بالتركيز خلال
حملاتها على مكافحه كل ما من شانه اهانه
الرموز الدينيه والمقدسات والافعال
الاستفزازيه المتعمده وجميع الممارسات
التي تعزع الامن والاستقرار والذي قد
يستغله تنظيم داعش والجماعات المتطرفه
حينما كانت لتغفيظ دعاياتها الاعلاميه وقت
يحتاج فيه العالم الى العمل سويا لنبدا
التطرف ونشر قيم الحوار والتسام
ان معركتنا ضد التطرف والارهاب تتطلب منا
بدل جهودا اضافيه لكسب العقول والقلوب
وليس فقط عبر الادوات الاعلاميه والثقافيه
والتربويه معميتها الفائقه ولكن ايضا عبر
تقديم نموذج عملي حي لوجود مستقبل افضل
قائم على التسامح والانفتاح والتنميه
المستدامه والازدهار وهو ما تجسده رؤيه
المملكه 2030 وتيلاتها حيث يصبح ابنائنا
وبناتنا الشباب هم من يصنع المستقبل
ويحتفي بالحياه فهم هدف الرؤيه وهم ايضا
عماد وتحقيقها وفي الختام اشكركم جميعا
على تلبيه الدعوه والمشاركه في هذا
الاجتماع والذي نامل من خلاله المساهمه في
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار والازدهار لبناء
مستقبل تنعم به اجيالنا القادمه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات